well yes this is a this is an individual  thing it may not be for everybody the  way I do it is I take the mushrooms and  they take about 40 minutes to an hour in  20 minutes to come on during that time I  sit quietly in the darkness and worry in  that period to expunge myself of worry  by getting a table all taken care of and  I recall all the people I've wronged and  all the terrible things I've done and  this is so that when it actually comes  on I won't be hit yes this is called yes  it's called to make a good examination  of conscience you go you go through the  commandments one by one  honor thy father and thy mother did I  honor my father and my mother thou shalt  not covet thy neighbor's wife did I  covet my neighbor's WA and so forth and  so on